[Music]
foreign
good evening to you you're watching the
Press preview of first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive and it's
time to see what's making the headlines
with the daily mirrors associate editor
Kevin McGuire we're also joined tonight
by The Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine
good evening to you both thank you for
joining us we'll be speaking to them
shortly they'll be joining us now just
until just before midnight tonight so
let's start by seeing what's on the
front pages of those newspapers now
starting with the daily mail it believes
a general strike could be on the way for
Christmas after another wave of
industrial action was announced today
nearly a third of all flight departures
could be canceled as a result of airport
staff striking that's on the front page
of the times tomorrow morning senior
military figures have said that Army
staff should not have to miss Christmas
in order to cover NHS staff on strike
that's the front page of the day
Telegraph the I claims the former Health
secretary met Hancock's decision to
stand down as an MP was prompted at
least in part by a letter of no
confidence due to be put forward by his
constituencies conservative Association
the mirror tomorrow suggests that Mr
Hancock could be eyeing a career in
television after his stint on I'm a
celebrity
the express implores Prince Harry stop
this portrayal of our beloved Queen
ahead of the release of his and Megan's
Netflix documentary which is tomorrow
morning the financial times has word of
the loosening of covert measures in
China it comes after Street protests the
likes which haven't been seen since
Tiananmen Square the Metro leads with a
bizarre story from Germany were a plot
to storm the country's Parliament has
been uncovered it doesn't end there
though there would be Rebels apparently
had a plan to install an eccentric
prince who was allegedly in on the plot
as their new leader of course we've also
been covering that all day here on Sky
News and the guardian leads with a story
on Michael Gove ignoring climate
warnings to approve the UK's first Coal
Mine in 30 years
the star previews England's World Cup
quarterfinal against France on Saturday
French Striker mbappe lives in Leicester
that's on the front page of the sun
tomorrow morning
and a quick reminder that by scanning
the QR code you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us
well let's meet our uh our paper
reviewers now we're joined tonight by
Kevin McGuire and Sarah Vine good
evening to both of you Kevin let's start
with you and start with the front page
of the Daily Mail according to them it's
beginning to look a lot like a Christmas
general strike what's your take on this
yeah there's no doubt there's a huge
upsurge in industrial action I think
that's uh uh over what we're putting it
back in 1926 the general strike nine
days was a quarter of the workforce on
strike that would be about seven and a
half million people now so something
like that it's the highest uh the most
industrial action since 1989 actually
not even 1979 it was so called window
discount 10 but never nevertheless
border force uh workers going on strike
uh on top of ambulance Crews setting the
date and you have posties you have
nurses versus the Royal College of
nursing's History National National
strike you can go around and around you
can see why it's happening because
living standards and under an enormous
squeeze we've got inflation 11.1 percent
consumer prices index 14.2 retail prices
index which includes mortgages and
people are being offered very very low
amounts so wages are actually going up
faster in the private sector than the
um public sector by about three times I
looked at the office for National
statistics figures and it's a six point
six percent in private public sector 2.2
so that's enormous cut in in living
standards there's gonna be a lot of
inconvenience for people and in truth
there is no easy answer to this and I
don't think the government uh has
handled it particularly well by pushing
away the unions for too long now it's
it's speaking to them but I don't think
there's anything concrete there so
you know put your seat belt on and get
ready for a rough ride yeah Sarah let's
bring you in now the the daily mail
saying that it's a general strike in
orbit name and then saying the families
of the young children will suffer the
worst cues because under 12s are not
allowed to use electronic passport Gates
as if you're lucky enough to be going
abroad over over the Christmas period
what's your take on it
well I think it's I think it's the
Christmas of it isn't it that I mean I
think a lot of people are sympathetic
towards public sector workers and
particularly those on the front line and
they do think they need pay Rises but
it's just it's just that this time of
year is particularly sensitive and
particularly since you know we've had
two years of covered and so a lot of
people haven't seen their relatives for
example I'm supposed to be going to
Italy for three days to see my dad who
has been very unwell
um on the 26th and I might probably now
not be able to go it's not the end of
the world but it will it you know it it
will we're in our Christmas
um I think the difficulty is that it
feels very political you know the unions
do fund labor I think this year
donations from unions to labor party
were sort of 1.6 million Kevin will
correct me if I'm wrong
um so it does feel like it's very
political it feels like the you know the
government on the back foot and the
unions are taking advantage of it which
is probably a very sensible tactic for
the unions but it just means a lot of
people will suffer and then other thing
to say is that there are a lot of people
who are on zero hours contracts who
don't have the protection of unions who
will be affected by all of this who
won't be able to get to work who will
who can't just put their hands in the
pockets but the thing about things like
this these sort of strikes is that they
don't affect the affect the well-off
people will just you know if you're
Harry and Megan you just hire another
private jet but if you're a normal
person and if you are also struggling
you can't buy yourself out of the
difficulties and so your Christmas will
be mad and that's the difficulty it's
very it's very emotional I think it
feels uh it feels it feels quite Grinchy
it doesn't help that of course Mike
Lynch rhymes with Grinch That's
obviously quite fun
it may be fun for the headline writers
those sub-editors the various papers and
you were kind of nodding and then not
nodding in in agreement and disapproval
there what would you like to say Kevin
well for instance the Border Force Union
the public and Commercial Services union
doesn't give any money and is not linked
to the labor party the Royal College of
Nursing doesn't give them money to the
labor party and isn't uh to do it at all
the rmt rail Union with Mick Lynch uh
the Grinch for uh uh for uh Sarah there
they don't give money to the labor party
they're not affiliated to the labor
party so I could see why there is a
political battle between the two main
parties labor attack at the government
government attacking labor but these
aren't political strikes these are just
basic bread and butter strikes that
people are worried about their
livelihoods their living standards in
some cases their jobs and that's why
they're going on strike and yes the
public are going to be inconvenienced
that you'll hear you'll hear words of
regret from people like Mick Lynch uh
Mark sawatka II but the fact is you go
on strike yeah there will there will be
a disruption but I think it is quite
wide support for these strikes it varies
sometimes I see majority of people back
the nurses now cancer treatment starts
to get canceled would that be the case
in in January I'm not so sure
um there's public support for the
ambulance Cruise
if people die as a result which is
possible I mean then probably uh cases
like that now because there are some few
ambulances and response times are so
appalling which is one of the reasons
they're going on strike because if
you're a professional uh you're a
paramedic you're an ambulance crew the
frustration of not being able to do your
job properly must be absolutely enormous
never mind the question of your your
living standard so I think when
everybody's everybody's squeezed there's
some respect for people who are standing
up for themselves and having a go and
trying to protect their living standards
well you mentioned support let's have a
look at the front page the days
Telegraph because they approached the
story with a different angle um Sarah
and they've spoken to uh Army officials
who say the Army is furious as soldiers
order to give up Christmas over strikes
they they the telegraph says that
they've been told that the military
believes it's not right for soldiers who
are banned by law from striking to have
to replace public sector workers walking
over the festive season so it looks like
sympathy is running thin Maybe from the
Armed Forces
well yeah I mean I mean they're in a
difficult because everyone always
expects the Army to step in and fix
everything when everything goes wrong
um yeah I mean I think they've got a
point why should they do it but I mean I
I don't know I mean I I think that I
think that you know people do have
sympathy for public sector workers I
really think they do I think a lot of
them are underpaid but I just think they
could have done this in January they
don't have to do it now at Christmas
when everybody's you know under quite a
lot of strain as it is already it you
know it it makes things a lot harder and
it doesn't really help their cause and I
think it's I think it is really
insensitive the unions to do this at
this at this time of year I think there
are plenty of other times to make the
argument
um you know you know when you're not
going to destroy people's people's
holidays
Kevin quickly
to be dragging on for some time and the
the rmt for instance didn't set
Christmas strike date because it had a
meeting with Mark Harper and the and the
rail company I thought they're going to
get a better offer and in the end the
offer full well short of what they went
but I I sympathize with the with the the
Armed Forces you know privates as it
mentions are on 22 000 pounds why are
army privates paid so low they're banned
from striking they don't organize just
being Oliver Twist please sir may I may
have some more doesn't get you anything
gets you very very thin drool and I can
see why they resent being used as a
strike breaking force a scab Army
turning the British army to a scab Army
it seems everybody just says get the
military get the military all the time I
see why they're fed up they want to do
their own job not everybody else's job
okay let's move on now on to the front
page of the Guardian tomorrow uh gov
ignores climate warnings to approve the
first coal mine in the UK for some 30
years we were told that this is a 165
million pound cumbrian site it's going
to add 400 000 tons of missions to the
UK total Sarah what do you make of
Michael gove's decision here
well as I understand it uh it's to do
with the fact that there was an
independent review of this of this coal
mine and the person doing it decided
that basically it would make no
difference whether the coal was mined in
the UK or whether it was imported from
abroad and therefore in terms of sort of
in terms of climate change and Net Zero
and all of those things it was sort of
there was no reason to to Halt it from
going ahead and so uh the independent
review recommended it and so Michael
went you know just took his advice and
and that's what they're doing I mean
they're saying it's going to be the
first Net Zero Coal Mine uh ever in the
history I mean the thing is that the
coal that it produces is Coke so it's
used in in the manufacture of Steel and
stuff so it's not the stuff that you put
in your fires so the idea the the
argument is is that you would import
this stuff anyway from abroad in order
to do this processing so why not just
mind it here very quickly because we're
going to head to a break in just a few
minutes a few minutes time what do you
think Evan has he got the right is this
the right decision do you think
that coal will be exported it's hiring
in Salford because it's controversial
because the Net Zero Target by 2050. all
the cool mine shots in 2049 is the plan
huge controversial but I can see for
some people in that part of Cumbria 500
jobs will be will be welcome back from a
mining family I think we've got to move
on from burning coal and digging it out
the ground
Okay Kevin for now thank you so much
Sarah thank you as well do say where you
are because we're back we're both in
just a few minutes time uh coming up on
uh Sky News in just a few minutes is a
soon to be XMP get him out of here we're
going to ponder what's next for Matt
Hancock coming up off this break don't
go away
[Music]
foreign
hi there welcome back you're watching
Sky News and the Press preview with me
now is Kevin McGuire and Sarah Vine both
of you welcome back to the program let's
crack on lots of great front pages to
get through tonight uh starting with the
eye one big story dominating that
newspaper tomorrow morning Hancock
forced out after local toys revolt
against their absentee MP Sarah what'd
you make of this
um but what doesn't surprise me one
little bit uh I don't know this is a
this is a family show
um I uh I think I think that what do I
think was he forced out or do you think
this is something he would do you think
I think he was definitely I think he was
definitely forced out I think he was
definitely forced out I think Matt would
not walk away from politics unless he
was forced out and he probably will come
back
um
how will he come back do you think
well I'm it might I don't know maybe
he'll maybe he'll stand for another seat
but he's uh yeah he's very I think he's
he was always very determined when I
knew him to become Prime Minister
um so I imagine that's probably still on
his agenda but uh yeah and I don't know
what new relationship he's going to get
with the British public I think he's
done he's done this SAS program hasn't
he so that's the next thing I guess
um maybe he'll come and do the sky paper
reviews with us you'd be welcome I'm
sure
um let's bring you in now Kevin and also
at the same time look at your newspapers
that front page as well tomorrow it is
the big story of course there's also
pictures of Megan Harry Will and Kate
but shamed MP targets TV riches Hancock
get me out of here Matt Hancock has his
eye on TV Fame according to the Daily
Mirror and announcing that he won't
stand again what do you think of this uh
but I've told he wants to do strictly
and I could see you know what happens it
seems to be in reality TV is you you get
punted around and you end up everything
maybe you'll end up on love Island uh
although Gina may not like that because
he is uh he's quitting politics to spend
more time with somebody else's family or
at least one member of that uh that that
family and he has these jump before he
was pushed the West Sussex conservative
associations that they didn't want him
but in truth rushy do not want him to go
until the general election because he
advert fear of by-election then well if
you're Hancock the 84 000 pound a year
question is why would you go earlier
than that you can just turn up for a few
votes straight stuff around
um Parliament use the cafes and the
restaurants I have somewhere that hang
his hat and uh there we are go off on
his new new life you don't sound too
sorry Kevin
well I'm not actually
um I don't entirely dislike him uh he's
very tigger-ish but I think when those
covered restrictions were so tough
people weren't seeing dying loved ones
and missing their family and then he's
got his hands all over his uh his
assistant breaking his own covered rules
I think it's just really really bad
behavior and yeah he says he was in love
and it was a great great Affair and all
that I'm sorry lots of other people had
to follow his rules and were being fined
and there he is just been very very
Cavalier about it so no I mean that's it
you can sit now with a toad on his head
and a string vest and drink cider for
all I care okay let's squeeze one more
story in before we see you again in the
11 o'clock hour and uh Sarah let's have
a look at the front page of Daily
Express again they've got Matt Hancock
on there as well talking about biggest
drop in house prices but their main
story of course is looking ahead to the
Netflix documentary that's coming out
tomorrow and they're saying stop this
portrayal of our beloved queen Harry and
Megan Stan accused of betraying the lake
Queen's trust by breaking the agreement
made when they gave up their Royal roles
are you looking forward to watching the
documentary tomorrow
no I am not and I have to get up at
seven o'clock because it drops as they
say at eight o'clock and so I you'll
have to watch it then
um it's just I I they did say I mean
Harry did Save the Queen supposedly you
know I'm not going to I'm not going to
trash your legacy and that's exactly
what he and Megan are doing uh for money
really and uh casting themselves as
victims I mean it was seeing Megan
yesterday or whatever it was in her
white ten thousand pound Louis Vuitton
dress wearing a big Bling Ring uh that
used to belong to Princess Diana you do
slightly think I'm sorry I don't really
understand what your problem is but I
don't know maybe I'm just old-fashioned
okay we'll leave it there for now thank
you very much Daily Mail columnist Sarah
Vine and the daily mirrors associate
editor Kevin McGuire we'll see you for
more at the 11 o'clock hour for now